[Music]
5 55 on your wednesday morning how about
changing some signs aimed at improving
your driving safety you know those signs
that warn you when the traffic signal
you're coming up on is about to turn red
well the nevada department of
transportation is changing a couple of
them here in town
as well as some other similar signs in
junior traffic buddy nerd
world they're all advanced signal
warning
systems asws and they're divided into
three general categories first there is
static that means that the warning's
just a sign alerting you that there's a
signal ahead then there's passive
which is the same as static although
they've added flashing lights to the
sign
then there's active which is sort of
like the passive signs but
those flashing lights are connected to
the upcoming traffic signal
after a long study about the
effectiveness of those various asws's
some are actually being taken out
completely a couple of the active ones
having their timing adjusted
ndot's got a website all about the
coming changes we got a link to it on
our website eightnewsnow.com you just
cook traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
and if there is some